and it's now my honor to present this
first time ever kobe bryant newly
designed trophy
and the kia mvp
to its only fitting
one of the nba's 75 all-time greats
steph curry
[Applause]
so the kobe bryant trophy going to the
uh 2022 kia
nba all-star mvp you've done a lot of
things in your career stefan but
all-star game mvp add that to the mantle
that's pretty special obviously uh
being back in ohio playing with the the
best guys in the league
and uh you know celebrating the highest
level of basketball and obviously this
trophy
has a very special meaning uh honor and
kobe gigi everybody it was lost two
years ago so uh very humbled very
blessed and
i really appreciate it can you express
to the folks here what it's like when
you're in the third quarter and you're
scoring 21 points and everything you're
throwing from anywhere is going in would
it like to to spend that amount of time
in that zone
it's fun it's like obviously a lot of
reps a lot of work and then this is the
freedom to just be creative and and have
fun with it and uh it's obviously great
when i get going the energy picks up and
uh i think the game kind of turned into
the right direction after that too
and i think it's testament to the change
and i think putting that target score up
there the defense intensifies there in
the fourth quarter and uh and every trip
means something absolutely i wouldn't
hear the the first uh time they put that
format in and i was watching at home and
you could definitely feel the intensity
turn all the way up and you know you got
to get a couple stops jared and joelle
was banging down low
you know demar braun hit two big shots
so
might have started off slow but it
definitely picked up in terms of uh you
know giving the fans a great show
just uh just too shy of the all-time
record
so i tried i tried
that's right
uh congratulations stefan very happy for
you he makes it look
staffordless
all right
team lebron
winning over team durant
here in the 2022 all-star game in
cleveland what a great host
this city has been